[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As enterprises
digitally transform themselves,
networks are at the foundation.
While networks are
constantly modified
to support your applications,
you need a single pane of glass
that can address all aspects of
troubleshooting and monitoring
so you can easily diagnose
complex connectivity
and network performance issues.
Network Intelligence Center
is Google Cloud's framework
for network monitoring across
the cloud and on premise.
It improves user experience,
security, and operations
by providing a
comprehensive platform
for network monitoring,
verification, and optimization
across the cloud and Datacenter.
Firewall Insights is a module
in network intelligence center
that helps you optimize
firewall rule configuration,
tighten up network
security boundaries,
and detect abnormal
traffic patterns.
Large enterprises often
have thousands, sometimes
tens of thousands, of
firewall rules configured
by different groups.
Over time, the large
number of rules
becomes unmanageable
and introduces
all kinds of security risks
and operation overhead.
The Firewall Insights
module helps you tackle
these challenging problems.
I'll walk you through
a few use cases
where you can leverage these
new functionalities to optimize
your VPC firewall configuration.
As firewall rules are
added by different people
at different times, new rules
can be accidentally shadowed
by existing rules and as a
result fail to take effect.
Without automated detection,
it's very hard for you
to catch this when managing a
large number of firewall rules
configured for the same VPC.
Suppose I
Have added a rule to allow
traffic from 10.1.0.0/24subnet
to access web app 2.
When I go to VM1 in the source
subnet with IP as 10.1.0.2
and try to reach VM2 tagged
with a web app 2, it fails.
To find out why, I'll go to the
network detail page for VM2.
Here are two rules
applied to this traffic.
The deny rule blocking traffic
from 10.1.0.0/16 range is
shadowing the allow rule that
allows traffic from a sub range
10.1.0.0/24.
To avoid such incidents
in the future,
you want to proactively clean
up your firewall configurations
and automatically identify all
firewall rules accidentally
overshadowed by other rules.
Firewall Insights in
Network Intelligence Center
provides you with a convenient
list of rules overshadowed
by other firewall rules.
A rule can be
either overshadowed
by a single or a combination
of multiple rules.
In this case, the
rule allowing traffic
on both port 8080 and
443 is overshadowed
by a combination of two deny
rules blocking HTTP and HTTPS
traffic respectively.
You can review each
shadowed rule in site detail
and adjust the rule settings to
match your application traffic
control needs.
In this second scenario,
I'll show you the allow rules
with no hit in sight to
help you clean up your
allow rules leftover
from past projects
and tighten up your
security boundaries.
To find out what these
unnecessary allow rules are,
I'll go to the Firewall Insights
in the Network Intelligence
Center.
On the allow rules
with no hit card,
I see a list of firewall
rules that I have not
been hit by any traffic
in the last six weeks.
We notice that there is a rule
for allowing internet traffic
to an app in a test
project, web app 1
that the project owner
forgot to clean up.
The firewall insides
module automatically
detect such leftover allow
rules so that you can get
the opportunity to clean it up.
Using Firewall Insights,
you can not only
identify problems in your
firewall rule configuration
but also obtain visibility
into abnormal traffic patterns
that you want to get alerted to.
Deny rule with hits helps you
capture the traffic blocked
by the deny rules and
detect external attacks
or misbehaving VMs in
your cloud deployment.
From the list, you
can easily drill down
to the corresponding
firewall logs
to review and find out where
the deny traffic came from.
In summary, Firewall
Insights automatically
detects overlapping
and misconfigured rules
to help you maintain the
right set of firewall rules
that protect your
cloud deployment
and brings real-time visibility
to your firewall utilization
statistics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]